my name is Doug roar I am a polyglot
developer uh who happened to end up
doing some Elixir work a little while
ago I'm going to kind of tell you the
story of how I got to do some Elixir
work why we ended up choosing
Elixir um and where we came from and
then some of the interesting stumbling
blocks we ran into so you don't run into
them as well um this is a little bit
about me um one of the big things
throughout my career is I have been
involved in um analyzing and mitigating
performance issues in systems be itnet
Ruby Elixir erlang sorts of things um so
this kind of problem is something that
I've done a lot of over the course of my
life in a lot of different languages um
and I learned something new every time I
do it so it's a lot of fun um so the
problem that we ran into um the client
uh is a home automation company that
does a lot of different things including
uh connected thermostats as one of their
devices and no it's not Nest it's
somebody else but um same basic concept
right you've got a you've got a
thermostat in the home connected via
Wi-Fi I want to be able to turn up the
temperature because I'm coming home
early so I pull out my iPhone and crank
up the temperature a couple degrees and
by the time I get home my my home is
nice and comfortable
um they had a very high-end product of
which they had about three or 4 thousand
on the market that that were actually
installed in people's
homes um and they wanted to expand that
to a broader audience so they built a
less expensive um slightly less high-end
system that was um going to be M
manufactured in the 100 to2 200,000 unit
range within the next year um we had an
existing system that that ran in Ruby
that handled the 3 to 4,000 thermostats
fairly well with a couple of exceptions
the big one being um anytime they had
any sort of networking issue at their
hosting provider when the thermostats
came back they all came back at the same
time and the system really couldn't
handle all of those new incoming
connections at once um but so the
question was can the existing Ruby
system scale to this you know orders of
magnitude larger number of devices that
we're planning on selling in the next
year um if so how do we make it do that
if not what do we do what are our
options um so again we had an existing
system so we built a performance testing
tool excuse me that could um simulate
load for a large number of of uh devices
look at a potential solution starting
with the existing one um run the test
see how close we could get um to what we
projected our load numbers to be both in
terms of these kinds of new connections
coming in all at once sorts of spikes
and then steady State load um try and
figure out okay it's not working where
isn't it working um why isn't it working
and trying and fix those things and then
when we got to a point where there
wasn't an obvious problem that we could
easily fix abandon that solution move on
to some other proof of concept to see if
we could get to a final um answer that
would actually work for
us um so we started out with the
existing solution which was based on
Ruby and an uh event Loop model called
event machine which uses I believe the
same code that things like node use lib
UV it's a a typical event Loop um that
already existed it was up and
running um we had some really
interesting problems when we tried to
scale that up um the first of which was
it it just could never handle the number
of new connections that we needed it to
um there may be some lower level tweaks
now that I know a little bit more about
how tcpip and excepter loops and and and
those kinds of things work that we could
have done but at the end of the day the
biggest problem for us
was as an evented looping system if you
don't yield back to the event Loop often
enough you end up stuck in places where
certain things are are totally consuming
the processor and totally consuming the
system and in our case what would happen
is we would pull all of the message that
we had off of uh a rabid mqq before we
could respond to any of them um and we
fixed a bunch of bugs in the amqp gem
which is what ruby uses to talk to
Rabbit mq um but couldn't find the right
place to put in a please yield back to
the reactor Loop um in order to make
that work and work
reliably um there's another system in
Ruby that's also known for handling
these kind of large concurrent systems
called Celluloid
doio um it uses an actor model or agents
to handle connections um the programming
model is a lot easier to understand um
than this event Loop style system
um but it ended up the only way we could
get the system to accept a large enough
number of connections per minute um was
to use J Ruby and at that point point
the system that we were looking at maybe
a single machine hosting 40 or 50,000
simultaneous connections was using 40 GB
of RAM um again at some point there may
be some things that we could have done
to lower that but I don't think it was
an order of magnitude sort of fixed so
we looked at that and said 40 gigs of
RAM for a bunch of active connections is
really not going to be feasible for this
system um so our next thought was we
should look at
llang um
as as many of you probably know ear
langang was was pretty much designed for
these kinds of problems um this is this
is what ear langang is really really
good
at um so concurrency is a lot easier to
do and is more supported by the runtime
in llang especially than a ruby based
system um or or pure MRI Ruby um OTP
forces you into doing things like using
the actor model in order to to implement
your system so if you stick with kind of
known patterns in llang you end up with
a system that should be scalable with
some caveats of your own making um and
clustering of of erlang is something
that is much easier to do because
earling supports clustering out of the
box um at least in its basic form so we
knew it eventually we're were going to
have a big cluster of these things and
because of the backend systems we were
talking to machine a May pick up a
message that is for a connection that
lives on machine D and we knew we had to
solve that problem eventually and in
earling that's much easier than what we
probably would would have had to do in
Ruby or something
else um so why Elixir and not
erlang um especially at the time Elixir
was really new I think we we started
looking at Elixir when it was at version
10 um so it's a very early use of
Elixir
um the client had some existing
experience with erlang um but nobody on
their team had written anything in llang
the people who had done that had had
left um they looked at some example
Elixir code said hey I can read this I
don't really know how to read the ear
langang um and at the end of the day we
decided that especially for a proof of
concept we could get this done faster
and in a more understandable way using
Elixir and if Elixir as a language
turned out to be a problem we could
always go back and and rewrite it in
erlang um we're talking about probably
500 lines of code at least in proof of
concept uh for this for this routing
system that we had to build so um as a
proof of concept we picked up Elixir um
and kind of stuck with it
throughout for those of you not familiar
with llang and elixir I want to talk
really quickly about some things um a
process in erlang is not an operating
system level process
um hundreds of thousands of processes on
a single erlang node are are really
common um and millions are not unheard
of um you use processes to maintain
state in in a similar sort of way that
you would um an instance of an object
object and an object-oriented language
in in different techniques but the same
kind of idea so you can use a process to
maintain State um processes talk to each
other via mailboxes
um and messaging um and and uh messages
are processed uh in
order um OTP sitting on top of ear
langang is the open Telecom platform and
it is useful for way more than Telecom
so if you look at that and go oh not
doing Telecom I don't need to you need
to know about OTP um there may be some
Fringe case where you know about OTP and
you decide specifically not to use it
but 99 times out of 100 OTP probably
will help you solve your problem in in a
better way than you could come up with
on your
own I am certainly not knowledgeable
enough in llang to be able to say oh I
don't want to use OTP for this um
so OTP is kind of an abstraction on on
top of
processes um that gives you the ability
to to manage State and react to messages
in a wellth thought out pattern so you
don't have to think about okay I've got
this big loop of receive a message and
then how do I handle that message in
this kind of larger chunk of code OTP
handles all those details for you so you
say I want a process that is kind of a
generic server and it's going to do
something
um it
um it provides uh a structure for your
application so OTP um applications are
generally large trees of Supervisors
that monitor other processes some of
which may be other supervisors some of
which may be
workers um you know there there is a
saying in the Earline Community which is
basically let it crash right so
supervisors watch their children and if
one of them dies they will re start it
um According to some rules that you set
up when you start up the supervisor um
and often times in the kinds of systems
especially that that Ericson was
building when they were building erlang
the answer is a retry is usually the
right way to do this and if you can
reset your system to a known good State
and then try again or continue from that
point um a lot of times things just work
and then you look at the exceptional
cases of okay I know exactly how to hand
error X I can write code to handle error
X but everything else let's just try
restarting the particular process that
died and nine times out of 10 that'll
work um and then you you define some
rules for what happens when it doesn't
and things keep restarting how does the
tree react to that how does supervisors
react to that and we'll get into more
detail on that in a little
bit um so I talked about supervisor
trees this this application that we were
writing is called ala which is a warrant
in the in waters ship down um the Ala
were kind of the police of the Warren of
rabbits um so that's where that name
came from um so we have a top level
supervisor that watches um some rabbit
mq communication processes um and then
we have this tree of tcpip stuff that's
going on we have a TCP supervisor and
then the two ends of that are the
listener and how do I get new
connections coming in and then the end
points which are individual connections
um and how do I handle those so each one
of those has a branch in this
tree um so that's kind of like the
really big picture this is how our
application is structured um you can see
a couple numbers in there um like the
TCP TCP acceptor there are a thousand of
those processes sitting there um we'll
get into y a th000 in a little bit um
but it gives you an idea of the scale so
TCP endpoints we were looking at 40 or
50,000 processes per node in our cluster
at least for proof of concept um so I'm
going to talk a little bit about some of
the things that we ran into as we were
building this system um and and what you
can do about them so I talked uh earlier
about the fact that we were attempting
to have a large number of of devices in
this case thermostats reconnect to our
system all at
once so if you had to bring the system
down which you had to fairly frequently
for code deploys on the Ruby side um
when you brought it back up they would
all just come thundering back in and
then the system would grind to a halt
and things wouldn't connect and then
they'd come back five minutes later and
try again and there was this kind of
long period before you got back to a
stable system um one of the things that
you have to deal with when you have a
large number of tcpip connections coming
in is how do you accept new
connections um the canonical example
that every language probably has
somewhere is you have a you create a
listen socket which is you know port
8080 or whatever your Port is you tell
the operating system I want to accept
connections on that socket and then you
Loop while you accept which is tells the
operating system to block and wait for a
new connection to come in once you get
that accept return value that's your
file descriptor your socket whatever it
is that your particular language
abstracts that away to and you hand that
off to some other thread some other proc
process something else and then you go
back to the top of that Loop and start
again um when you're talking about a
thousand new connections a second that
doesn't work really well anymore because
you can't go through that Loop fast
enough just accepting a new connection
handing it off going back accepting a
new connection and handing it off so you
you end up building something called an
acceptor pool um I had never really had
to deal with something at this scale
before I did not know what an acceptor
pool was so so we ended up building one
um so why do we need one we talked about
you know single-threaded listen accept
doesn't really work very well but it
ends up that you can have multiple
processes all calling accept on a single
listen socket and when a new connection
comes in only one of them will be woken
up and all the other ones are still
sitting there waiting so if you've got
an eight core machine you can have eight
of them accepting new connections pretty
much
simultaneously um so the answer to this
is have ACH bunch of acceptors all
sitting there waiting on that listen
socket um so we we ended up doing this
and I'll walk through some code to show
you what this looked like
um the the answer to the next question
is should you build your own and the
answer is probably no um I didn't know
that we were building something called
an acceptor pool when I started this we
built it and then we kind of figured out
hey we we built an acceptor pool this is
kind of cool and we posted something
something on Reddit and somebody said
you know you just built Ranch which is
an llang library that is an accepter
pool so everyone in this room now knows
you do not have to build your own
acceptor pool at least if you're using
llang I'm sure most other languages have
some form of this um so if you're doing
Earl look at Ranch if you're doing
Elixir there's a reagent which is a pure
Elixir Elixir acceptor pool um but the
the learnings were really interesting
from that particular part of the project
so I'm going to walk real quick through
some
code
um TCP
supervisor is not really very
interesting we talked about that tree
where we've got the TCP supervisor and
then we're just kind of we have the
listener side and the endpoint side so
this is uh um an OTP supervisor written
in
Elixir um it has two children and we're
basically saying this is how we're going
to set up the tree um when you call
supervise it tells OTP these are the
children that I need to start up please
start them up for me um we'll get into a
couple of different things about um this
strategy in a minute but um that's the
basic idea is you're defining your tree
here so if we go look at TCP listener
supervisor um so my supervisor my TCP
supervisor starts up and says hey I need
a listener supervisor so this is the
method that eventually function function
I'm an object-oriented programmer I have
to stop saying method when I'm talking
about functional languages um so this is
the function that gets called um this
start link function gets called um
initially and then OTP will eventually
call this init function which get which
gets past our configuration that tells
it like what port I'm supposed to use
and things like that um the other thing
is this acceptor count so I said we had
a thousand processes sitting on that
listen socket um we we made that a
tunable number we set it to a thousand
and it worked fine so for the proof of
concept we left it alone um as I said
processes in earling are very very
lightweight um you know a typical Java
thread I think has a 2 megabyte memory
footprint or something like that and I
think an Elixir or an llang uh process
is somewhere in the 100 bytes for a new
process it's much much smaller so having
a bunch of them sitting around is very
low overhead um but we made it to able
just in case we needed to have more or
fewer
um and then we start up a whole bunch of
TCP acceptors but we don't do that here
this is just telling again telling OTP I
am going to have some children of this
type and usually it just starts oneup
for you but because we have this
strategy thing here so what how am I
going to deal with um my children um and
I'll get into some more details on that
but a simple one forone strategy says
basically I'm going to start them up
dynamically um so don't start any for me
just know that this is what what shape
they take these are the parameters that
are common to all of them and how I want
to deal with restarts and then I start
up a whole bunch of them in this little
en. each walk through my acceptor count
and start up a bunch of acceptors that
all listen on that same
port uh
that one so the endpoint supervisor is
similar in that it's going to sit and
just watch a whole bunch of tcpip
endpoints um we'll get to this in a
minute remember that's important um
we'll talk about restart strategies um
but this does the same kind of thing it
just starts up a new tcpip endpoint we
assign it um a uu ID uh so that we can
communicate back and forth between the
backend processes which are still
written in Ruby and our
our this is basically a message router
between tcpip and rabid mq uh so when
something comes back from the Ruby side
we know where to put it and then we
start up in endpoint um so that's kind
of kind of the the the quick overview
tour of the tcpip stuff um I want to
talk a little bit more about restarts um
so this was a fun problem so we're
working on a proof of concept um
and we have this testing tool that'll
connect 5,000 new connections written in
go interestingly enough because we had
something that was written in go that
basically did this already um so we want
to test 40,000 simultaneous connections
we spin up another
AWS uh instance big giant box and spin
up a whole bunch of testing tools on it
and then we'd go through this system and
everything looks beautiful we got 40,000
connections running they're all routing
their data back and forth everything is
great and then we go oh I want to tweak
some parameters on my client so i' kill
one of the eight testing instances that
were running and the entire supervisor
tree would just collapse in on itself
and everything would
disconnect we're like I'm sure we've got
a configuration problem somewhere we'll
figure that out later so we walked
through making sure all the other hard
problems were solved and then we came
back to this and said all right so why
is it that every time I disconnect one
of these things the entire tree just
kind of implodes now it started back up
and you could start right up making
connections again it's not like the
system imploded it's just we walked all
the way back up that tree and shut
everything down and restarted all of it
um and this is when we get into a couple
different things uh with OTP the first
one is restart
strategies excuse
me so how do I re how do I as a
supervisor restart my
children um if one of them dies there
are a couple of different thing ways you
can do this one for one which is
basically a a child dies I should
restart that child um one for all is
used if all of your children depend on
each other and if any single one of them
dies I need to restart all of them to
make sure they're all in a known good
State together uh rest for one is an
interesting one you saw in in the
supervisors that these um
uh that's not a good example let's look
at
TCP
supervisor um these things are are are a
list right so there's an order to them
um if you have multiple things that
depend on a depends on b b depends on c
c depends on D um you put them in the
correct order in that list and let's say
C dies well it'll restart C and it'll
restart D because it knows that d came
after C you know so the fourth one came
after the third one I need to restart
three and four but one and two are still
okay um that's what rest for one is and
then this simple one for one is is the
same as one for one um except the
assumption is you're starting things
dynamically um and that allows OTP to
not track some state in the supervisor
that otherwise it would as far as the
order of starting things and stuff like
that so it's a little bit more efficient
uh if if you're dynamically starting a
bunch of
children um so that's number one but
that still didn't solve our problem
number two is maximum restart frequency
um there are two numbers that you can
tweak in a supervisor to decide whether
or not it should restart itself if it's
children are dying um max T and maxr are
those two things Max T is the time
window in which it should be analyzing
these things as a sliding window and Max
R is the maximum number of child restart
s that happen before the supervisor goes
wow there's really something wrong maybe
it's like my state that's the problem so
I need to restart
myself um and those two numbers can be
tweaked but obviously we have 200,000
thermostats out in the wild right I
don't want to restart my supervisor if
five thermostats disconnect because
that's going to happen all the time so
you can't make that number really big in
our case because we we we don't want it
to be really big we want it to be
infinite Infinity right we don't care
um but that's not the right answer to
that question either the right answer is
talking about child
specifications um so I'm going to say
this and then I'll show you the code
there there are three different ways you
can tell the supervisor uh to behave
when its child dies the first one is I
should always restart the child if it's
if it dies doesn't matter whether it
said hey everything is great but I'm
stopping now it'll restart it anyway um
that's permanent transient is is it's
okay if a child stops if it tells me I'm
okay that I'm stopping it terminates
normally and there are ways to indicate
that when you stop a
process and the third one is temporary
which is what we cared about or what we
wanted which is never restart it it's
okay um so if you can imagine somebody's
thermostat in their house their their
Wi-Fi dies or their cable modem dies
well their connection is lost I as a
supervisor I don't care it'll come back
in 5 minutes and Rec connect so I don't
do anything strange just let those
things die um and that's restart the the
CH restart in the child specification so
if we look at again
TCP
endpoint
supervisor excuse me um so this is the
specification of what my CH the children
of the TCP endpoint supervisor are going
to look like
and this was the thing that solved our
oh my God the entire tree implodes on
itself problem right so if you think
about all the stuff I've talked about
the maxt and maxr settings they both
default to five So within a 5-second
period if five of your children die you
should restart yourself we hadn't said
anything other than the default values
so we would kill 5,000 Connections in
about two seconds and the whole thing
would just kill itself right so this is
where you end up with this this
within the specification of the child
telling the parent how do I deal with
restarts um and these guys are temporary
it's okay we start them up they live
they die don't do anything um and that
that was what solved our particular
problem but the Journey of figuring out
how to make this work correctly was
walking through all of these different
things restart strategies learning that
what we really should be doing is simple
one for one restart strategies um
recognizing that Max T and maxr really
aren't helpful for our particular
situation but they may be for somebody
else's and then finding the child
specification restart stuff which is
what we we really
needed um and
that is actually the talk in it of
itself so I have blown through this way
faster than I uh have done in the past
so I have tons of time for questions um
I can show you some other interesting
things in the history of this code base
I can talk about some of the other stuff
that we ran into with with llang um and
and one good one is understanding the
actor model um and mailboxes so if you
saw right here in fact we assign a uu ID
to every connection that comes in uh
well I need some way to be able to find
that process based on the uuid because I
get a message back from Rabbid mq that
says hey I've got a message for this
connection please send it to it right
here's the uid do that well again not
not being experienced in OTP at the time
we started this project our first
thought was well let's create a process
that has a map from process ID or from
uu ID to process ID which sounds like a
really great idea except we're not
running in a world where 72 different
things can all access that one process
at the same time right you have a
mailbox you have to send that process a
message that says hey I've got this
connection ID tell me what process ID is
associated with it so we built our own
bottleneck right we now have a single
process that holds all the state for
every message route that has to happen
and we can only ask it one question at a
time um that doesn't work very well so
it ends up that
um that
um OTP has a solution to that llang has
a solution solution to that and that's
Global
naming um endpoint
supervisor where do we start
this give me just a
second so there's our
ID right sorry TCP endpoint we want to
look at the endpoint now
um so to make our lives easier we have a
little structure that defines what the
state of the endpoint is and there's a
bunch of stuff about handling messages
in the proper order because again we've
got a bunch of things listening on
Rabbid mq and a different machine May
pick up our message and want to Route it
to us um the really important thing
talking about dealing with these Global
names um there are a couple different
ways you can name a process in earling
either you just have a reference to its
PID and then you can just call to it or
you can give it a name of some kind
there are local names which have to be
atoms um and in erlang as with a lot of
other languages atoms are never garbage
collected so it's not a good idea to
generate a bunch of new atoms and keep
generating more atoms because you'll
just run out of memory eventually um so
that's not that's not the right answer
um however Global names take a binary
which you can create a binary out of a
uu ID um a binary is just binary data
right so um earling actually allows you
to say name this thing globally which we
needed for our clustering stuff anyway
because that means actually machine a
can just say I've got a message for
something that's got this ID please send
it to it and llang will'll figure out
where in the in the cluster that thing
lives and send the message to it
automatically so this was pretty much
all of the code we needed to
write a to handle that mapping in a way
that wasn't bottlenecking the entire
system and B to allow us to Route
messages to the right connection right
which machine is this thing living on in
the cluster
um uh so this this gives it a global
name with that ID and then the send
which again gets picked up the rabbit
the rabbit mq listener calls
send says it's got a global name with
this connection ID and routes it to the
right
place
yes
yes yes yeah and we started look we
started looking at we started looking at
using S tables for it and and at the
same time figured out that Global naming
existed um and decided that that was
that seemed to be a reasonable solution
to the problem you're right um and in a
lot of cases that's not a good answer um
and and essentially intellectually
sharding across a number of processes is
the right answer so um he mentioned two
other ways that we could deal deal with
this right we're talking about a uu idea
as a series of bites and you could Shard
across a whole bunch of processes using
the first bite as a key right so I can
have 256 processes each one of which has
a submap of all of the process IDs and I
get a connection ID I pick the first
bite I go oh I need to send it to that
one to get my map back um as I said we
we kind of figured out ETS tables and
Global naming at the same time and went
with global naming um but it's not
always a good answer and for those kinds
of problems where you found yourself in
a bottleneck that's a that's often the
right answer um
if you're not talking about finding a
process right this was a a very special
case where there was a different answer
to the problem but if you need to find
ways to Shard your information your
state across a bunch of processes that's
another that that's another good answer
for how to do it um the third one is ETS
tables
so Earl will let you store data out of
process in a table somewhere called an
ETS table and then go back and get it by
key it's a pretty simple key value store
but it's enough that we could have done
we could have solved this problem that
way as well right every time I create a
new connection I put it into an ETS
table with the process ID and the key
and the connection ID as the key and
then as I come back I can just go look
up the process ID in the in the ETS
table um the downside to that for us was
when we went to a clustered solution
with Rabbid mq we could have a single
machine pick up the message and then use
Global naming to Route it to the right
place whereas if we had if we had stored
things in ET tables not distributed
across all the all the Clusters all of
the different machines would have to
pick up that same rabid mq message which
Rabbid mq supports but it takes more
Network overhead um and then the one
that has the connection could have gone
oh I got it send it off and everybody
else could have just ignored it um and
then there's Amnesia which is
distributed anyway
um you you can get into another layer
down where you've got some
distributed
um shared data that you can you can use
with amnesia but as I said for us the it
seemed the right answer was using Global
naming in this particular
case
um so we have about 11 minutes I am
happy to to entertain
questions
um we
actually yes yes yes yes absolutely so
the question was we had we probably had
some pretty robust logging in order to
don't go to sleep on me there we go um
we probably had some pretty robust
logging in there um honestly for the
most part we did a lot of this with with
small bits of logging where we where we
were finding problems um and then
removing it when we didn't need it but
once we got past the proof of concept
stage we
actually um put logger l a g g r which
is an earling library for doing logging
into the system and started to
instrument it because you don't want to
I mean this this is all um at the proof
of concept was successful point in the
code it got more complicated after this
but for demo purposes it's a lot easier
to look at this and say oh this is how
this all worked um but we we did start
to instrument a lot of those things
things um and the key is to be able to
understand you know things like log
levels and what do you care about when
and you know ignoring the things you
don't in when you're in production um I
think that's probably true of any
programming language right most most
logging systems let you turn on and off
certain levels um and so when you're in
a diagnostic
mode when you're really running into
problems you can crank up logging um the
guys from Riot games were talking about
being able to enable and disable logging
for a particular user at different
levels which is a really neat idea right
I know that a particular user is having
a particular problem I can just go in to
a live shell in llang and turn on
additional logging for that user and not
overwhelm the system just with logging
data but get more information on that
particular user um to be able to
understand where the problem
lies
uh no so the question was sorry the
question was did we ever run into um
issues where Elixir had put an
abstraction on top of erlang that
prevented us from doing something we
needed to do and did we have to drop
down to ll in order to do those things
and for this syst know um and
I I've never heard of anybody who's
really run into I can do something in
llang that I can't do in
Elixir um the more I used Elixir you
you'll learn you have to at least be
able to read llang because so much of
the documentation and so many of the the
open source libraries that you're going
to want to use are written in erlang and
anything you can any Library that's an
earling Library you can call from Elixir
um so there there's there's pretty much
total transparency between the two
languages as far as being able to call
out to llang libraries and things like
that um and in fact a lot of the stuff
that we used were were base erlang and
OTP libraries the SSL library that we
used the socket stuff that we're using
is all straight out of OTP and llang um
there are now wrappers around a lot of
those things or as I said there's
there's like an accepter pool
implementation that's written in in pure
Elixir um at the time most of those
things were either just barely forming
or weren't there but we didn't have any
problems because we could just look at
you know learn you some
llang um and figure out how to do a lot
of this stuff and use use use llang
where or call into llang where we needed
to but no we never found anything in
Elixir that was like oh wow I really
can't do what I want to do and I know I
can do it in llang so I'm going to have
to go write this particular module in
erlang or anything like that
yes
um so the question was what language
features did we use from Elixir um I
will tell you that in the example code
that we looked through it's pretty
straightforward you could have written
all of this in llang and there was
nothing really that that was different
there are however some libraries that
we're using that we have either modified
or are in the middle of modifying to
submit patches to there's one in
particular um at one point because of uh
a deficiency on the Ruby side we had to
punt on rabbit mq and build something in
reddis to do the the the one one way of
the
messaging um without getting into
details but that meant we needed a
reddis client and there is one there's
there's an earling reddis client and
there's even an Elixir wrapper around it
but I don't know if you've ever seen red
if you've ever used redus there are I
don't know what 150 or 200 operations
that you can call on a on a reddish
server to do things um I'm in the middle
right now of rewriting that reddis
client which literally defined each one
of those by hand and only had about 20
of them so every time we needed
something that wasn't there yet we had
to add it and then you know we'd submit
poll requests and stuff like that um
interestingly enough the reddest people
build their documentation from a Json
file that describes every operation and
its parameters um so I'm in the process
of writing a macro that takes that that
Json file and literally creates the
reddis client including every available
operation on
redis just by reading the Json data um
so there are some really interesting ma
things you can do with macros and elixir
that really didn't come through in this
particular talk and unfortunately I'm
not quite done with that code um but
that those kinds of things are are
pretty common in
Elixir
yes to the question
right so yes so the question is does
Earline give you um insight into
performance metrics within the Earl VM
itself right like mailbox deps and
things like that um there are an awful
lot of libraries that provide some very
detailed and interesting um live metrics
or reported metrics out of erlang um and
yes you can see lots of those things
unfortunately in this project um I I was
working as a consultant for another
company and the contract ended so that
was kind of the end of my work on this
project um we didn't get to that point
of operationalizing the system but yeah
you would definitely want to and would
be able to fairly easily uh monitor
those kinds of things um somebody
recently like very recently just just
put out a little PDF book um um about
running erlang systems and the kinds of
things and I I'm sorry I can't remember
the name off the top of my head of the
of the book um I'll try and find it and
tweet it um after the talk here but they
they talk a lot about monitoring and
logging libraries and what you can do
with them so it's a really good resource
in the
back erlang and anger thank you very
much yes that's the name of the book um
and it's like 97 pages and I I de
powered it on my way here actually I
think it came out the day the day I was
traveling um so really really nice
collection of lessons learned from from
their experiences running earling
systems
yes so the question was uh Elixir is a
dynamically typed language does um the
compiler give you any feedback on on typ
or things like that um so and the answer
is both Elixir and llang are dynamically
typed but they also support specking
your functions uh and there's a tool
called dialyzer that you can run on your
application um assuming the libraries
you're using are specked and it will
warn you about potential violations of
the specs um so that's definitely a good
tool to look at um if you want to get
some of
the safety features of a statically
typed language while using erlang um
specking your specking your functions
and using dialyzer is the way to do
that any other
questions
yes I'm sorry can you speak up just a
little
bit
okay so the question was um why did we
use HTTP versus something like xmpp as a
protocol so so first of all I if it
wasn't clear we weren't using HTTP we
were using
TCP um but but the protocol was not HTTP
that being said the protocol that they
used was a custom text based protocol um
that was very verbose and not real real
efficient um and one of the things they
ended up doing fairly far along in the
project as they're building these
thermostats is they mve to
protobuf um as as a protocol for
transferring data um because the text
based protocol was just really really
verbose um and was was you know just
unnecessarily verbose and also
complicated so it wasn't verbos and
human readable it was verbos and ugly um
so it it it didn't provide any really
useful things so they they they moved to
protuff for
that okay thank you all very much it is
time